Roger are you nervous about everything
that's going on right now that we won't
talk about the worst part of this is
being broke I mean you understand since
the last time I have been on your show
I've lost my home my insurance a lot of
little savings I had my ability to make
a living because people pay me to run
and talk and of course the things they
want me to write and talk about are the
very things I'm not allowed to talk in
right at all
it's uh in the in the blink of an eye
you can lose everything
how did you lose your whole eye your
home well because I'd have to pay
everything I have to lawyers and I could
no longer pay the rent in the property
that I was in I moved from a nine
bedroom house to a one-bedroom apartment
had to do the move myself with my life
renting a truck on the last day of the
move in a kind of a freak accident the
truck slips out of gear and rolls over
my wife's ankle breaking it is I speak
to you now I'm headed down to the car
pound in Fort Lauderdale because I just
got my car impounded for parking tickets
I didn't even know I had it's one of
those days one more Jim and Sam catch up
with full episodes and interviews from
celebrity guests anytime on demand using
the Sirius XM app
[Music]